it's no turning back for the government
on plastic bag following on TV the
penalties are the highest in the world
four years in jail and the maximum
penalty is 38 thousand US dollars we
cannot continue living in this kind of
an environment that is whole that is so
polluted with plastic bugs plastic
wastes something needs to be done
[Music]
it's very clear that they're not going
to be any arrests this week as we will
familiarize themselves with a new
regulation for next week
[Music]
Kenya before the ban was Nestor I felt
that I should do something
I started complaining I started writing
on why plastic bolts should be banned
one day the cabinet secretary tweeted
back she supported my campaign two years
later she banned plastic pots we had to
set the penalties so high so that we as
citizens understand the dangers of this
polythene bags and the plastic
pollutants initially I lost some
customers my observation is they are
touching up they're coming with a
reusable but it's no more for human
beings they resist change but in the
long run they adapt
my end goal is not to see that we don't
have plastic my goal is to see most
sustainable use and the Second Life of
plastic is where we need to begin
we are destroying our own life ever you
see plastic when you go fishing we see
plastic when you're pulling your nets to
catch more plastic than fish I had a
dream to do something to make people
understand the importance of the
environment we are making a beautiful
plastic towel
completely made of pure recycled plastic
from the keel to everything
I think is the fast in this world this
circular economy philosophy is beginning
to get traction here innovators have
been able to produce beautiful reusable
products using plastics and I able to
earn some income and we're very excited
about them when I see plastic I see Karl
I see beauty I see something that I can
use to make something we cannot call
those things trash we just call them
recyclables
[Music]
recycling is not totally self
sustainable people don't realize how
much work and cost goes into recovering
it from the environment somebody has to
go pick it up somebody has to give it to
somebody else the guys in the streets
were making few shillings the first
environmentalists
[Music]
Ali designs every piece of the boat you
bring us the shape and were able to
build a mold for it we're all burnt
plastic we melt we compress it let it
cool that's basically the process it
looks like his wood but it's not a word
is fewer plastic it's not perfect we
know it it cracks it Ben you know it
breaks but it lasts forever
construction products create a good end
use of plastic in can we say it will
last a life of your shamba the life of
your land
[Music]
the first communication of human lives
was through the sea there's no plane was
only down the dowel is communication our
scanners walk is just the beginning of
big things to come
to convert wasting took something
valuable it takes that vision it takes
perseverance to do that our plastic doll
is a message to the world we have to
tell our young kids the importance of
taking care of our environment because
the the leaders tomorrow is better that
we involve them and be truthful to the
coming generation
[Music]
you